oh
okay why don't we why don't we go ahead
and get started um
boys this interesting turn out here i
see some some old faces in the crowd
here
supporting one of their former
classmates anyways
today
our conference
as sometimes occurs is a
master's thesis defense
and
most of you in the room know
julian lipscombe who's been with us for
a while and now um appears to be
reaching the end
of his
ohsu informatics journey as you can see
he's he's all dressed up because he's
got a real job now which i guess i don't
um
anyways
i
i remember
i remember first getting email from
julian probably about i don't know about
three years ago
he had been looking at the uc davis
program and they were undergoing some
troubles and so he ended up enrolling
here
and then i remember i was in
i was attending a conference in
sheffield england
in like july before he started and so i
had the opportunity to to meet him
then
and
then of course he he joined us he uh
actually came to us with quite a bit of
experience uh masters in uh information
systems from uh uh
sheffield university is that technically
how they are university of chef
the university of sheffield um
which actually i'm going back to this
summer because uh they there's an
informatics meeting there in july that
they asked me to be the keynote speaker
um
anyways he uh uh was um
a um
a
very good student and never hesitated to
uh fill us in on his opinions on things
which which we actually did appreciate
um and now he's
ready to defend his master's thesis
let me actually acknowledge one other
person in the room uh dr lynn flowers
who's one of our distant students who
as i always say to the distant students
if you're ever in portland drop on by
and that's exactly what he's done um and
actually with him i said you know
there's this cool new thing you could do
called the tram you know so he uh rode
the tram up the hill
so
anyways um so as you know the way that
we uh handle uh masters thesis
defense
defenses
is that um the uh
candidate uh
the defender whatever it's called gives
his talk
and then then it's open to the
general
floor for a discussion and then um all
of
everyone except the
examination committee
leaves the room and then they ask him
any additional questions
and then he leaves the room and then
they decide whether or not he has
met the criteria for passing and
many of you in the room have been
through this
so anyways
without further ado i'm going to turn it
over to
julian
thank you
is that okay
can everybody hear me
right um well thanks bill um
surprisingly enough the uh the tram
isn't the highlight of my trip because i
i don't like those sort of suspended
things so i think i'll probably give
that one a miss
um as bill mentioned um i was a
full-time student here for a couple of
years i left in august and went back to
my native land
so now i just i don't speak funny
anymore i just speak normally
so this is my my oral thesis defense uh
my study was this is actually my my
short title of my project would you
believe um i think the actual thesis is
a bit longer but it's um it was a study
looking at people with visual impairment
in oregon and where they went to
retrieve and receive health information
and the there's a sub subplot here and
i also looked at internet and
non-internet users
within rural and suburban urban areas of
oregon
with that that's uh this is the outline
of my presentation um
my rather grandiose may names of study
which quickly fit the dust but i'll put
them down here anyway
background into areas of
a previous research into the area
um following the background of my aim
may names um
i ended up with a series of research
questions
um so i've listed them there then go
into the methodology
results
and discussion conclusions
any potential future research that may
come out of my my rather small
study and finally the
even though it may be the most important
thing the acknowledgements at the end
especially considering what's going to
happen after the uh after my
presentation the acknowledgements are
definitely the most important thing
um
so these were before i started the study
these were my main names of the project
um
they're kind of rather broad and general
in nature
where and how people with visual
impairment in oregon currently retrieve
and receive their health information
what are the experiences of people with
visual impairment when they search for
health information on the internet
and what barriers and obstacles were
people
with visually impaired experience in
when accessing health information
or even just using computers
now we go into a bit of a section uh
looking at the background of the study
kind of previous research into the areas
the pew internet
group have done a series of
studies looking at
people's activities on the internet and
increasing use of the internet to search
for various bits of information
in 2005 they did a report which said
that 79 of internet users have searched
for information on at least one major
major health topic
which equates to around 95 million
american adults which is
a really large number when you consider
that i don't think there isn't that many
people in the whole of the uk
but only 59 of american adults also
reported that they had internet access
one of the previous reports
that they they carried out two years
previously
suggested that online online health
seekers were mainly motivated to search
for health and health information
that relates to actions that might need
to they they might need to take to
address specific health concerns so it's
very much an individual thing where uh
when and if they can you okay
okay
maybe it's my microphone being hidden
let's
hopefully use that is that better
okay
maybe it's just my accent you're having
trouble with it's
according to andrew it's gone back to my
english state it was previous to uh
coming here so
um
so yeah basically what what the few
reports suggested was that um people
have individual concerns and when and if
they need to address that then they'll
search for health information at that
point
the report found the most common health
topics of online searches were
information about a specific disease or
a medical problem which is probably not
surprising
and also a certain treatment or
procedure
but the next two categories are kind of
more
categories that seem to be happening
more and more
recently kind of people researching diet
and nutrition and worrying about
exercise and fitness
before i could embark on the study i
wanted to get a grasp of um how many
people actually in the u.s actually had
visual impairment or some form of
disability
um the u.s census of 2000 reported that
there was 49.7 million within the united
states
who had some sort of long long lasting
condition or disability
um and 3.6 of the total population or
9.3 million people
were reported as having some sort of
sensory disability either a site or a
hearing
impairment
a report by the national eye institute
in 2002
documented the prevalence of visual
impairment and blindness within the us
of just those aged 40 and over and they
found that there was nearly three and a
half million people suffering from
vision impairment which was an overall
national average of 2.85
this report actually
um went
state by state
and they found that in oregon there was
there was nearly 45 000 people
which was 2.94 percent of the population
who were suffering from
some form of visual impairment
our good friends at pew they'd also done
a report looking at
the distribution of internet users in
the united states
during 2003
and found that people with disabilities
were less connected to the internet
than other groups of americans a drop of
like 20 percent
with 38 of people with disabilities
reporting
using the internet compared to 58 of the
sample
and the fifth of these people actually
stated that disability made use of the
internet difficult
i've used of those people who did who
said that they didn't use the internet
28 said that their disability impaired
or made impossible the use of the
internet
report by the national
telecommunications and information
administration
um differentiated actually
differentiated people um with visual
impairment from the rest of people with
other disabilities
and they compared their uptake of
internet use with age group
controls and found that
um though for those people aged under 25
it was very similar
in terms of people
percentage using the internet but as the
as the people got older the disparity
widened
but there was also a similar overall
frequency of actually using the internet
such as healthy information
the american foundation for the blind
estimated the number of in 1999
estimated the number of people
um with visual impairment who were
actually using computers and they
estimated there was one and a half
million people
in 1999
and the number of people who had visual
uh visual impairment who were age 15 and
older who regularly use the computer
with nearly a million people
with regard to the accessibility of the
internet for people with disabilities
there are some initiatives and
governance already in place
one organization with guidelines on
accessibility is that
the web accessibility initiative the
worldwide web consortium or w3c
um but these uh this guide these
guidelines aren't well known and they're
not generally conformed to
um so you move on to like a federal bill
which is section 508 of the
rehabilitation act um which deals with
accessibility of computing technology
but these that only actually applies to
companies who have governmental
contracts or federal agencies
and this isn't regularly enforced either
however the american foundation for the
blind did report that more organizations
are asking the designers to make their
sites more accessible to people with
um
with some form of disability
um but this was less
social responsibility or concern and
more financial concerns they found that
people
had online stores had a great deal to
gain from people who prefer shopping
online and
rather than a store which is just a
general phenomenon and probably unlikely
to be specifically to do with people
with disabilities
um the other part of my studies i wanted
to
see if there was any variation between
the internet use of people within
geographical areas um and the pew also
did a view report also did a
pre-project also did a report in 2003
which compared
internet use between geographical areas
and found that
people living in rural areas were less
likely to use the internet
this was consistent with a previous
study done by the same office in 2000
they suggested that the variants were
driven by
low-income rural individuals
the fact that rural people tended to be
older and had lower levels of
educational entertainment
but there seemed to be little variation
in searching for health information for
those people who actually use the
incident
the final part of background um is there
there have been very few studies
specifically looking at
people with visual impairment and
searching for health information
and
but rather than kind of listing them all
out for you there was a report done by
beverly etal who were actually at
sheffield university or university of
sheffield i should say correctly
who did a systematic review of the
existing literature and found that few
studies actually examined the unique
health information needs of people with
visual impairment
instead they
were more interested in establishing
a healthy lifestyle or health promotion
as the basis of their study
the authors argued that three general
hypotheses were being used um
people with visual impairment have the
same
same
wide range of health information needs
as a general population
uh people with visual impairment with
disadvantage and people with visual
impairment simply require themselves
same health information but in in
alternate formats
um
in in the conclusion i'll address
whether my study actually supported
these three hypothesis or not
but they also suggested that the fourth
hypothesis needs to be created which
assumes that people with visual
impairment have unique health
information needs and requirements
so following the background and looking
into the research uh previous research i
arrived at four specific research
questions that i wanted answering um
from my study
and in the discussion i'll i'll see
whether i actually found answers to
these specific questions or not
they're aware do people with visual
impairment go to satisfy their health
information needs and requirements
what barriers or obstacles exist that
prohibits or stops these people with
visual impairment from using online
health information resources
are there variations in the health
information seeking patterns of people
with visual impairment in rural areas
compared to suburban urban areas
and what suggestions or improvements
with people with visual impairments like
to see
with relation to health information
resources both online and
however creating a set of research
questions was the easy part the next
step was actually finding volunteers to
take part in my study
with help from the oregon commission for
the blind offices both in portland and
in coos bay which is about 250 miles
south
west on the coast as they would indicate
i managed to locate 28 willing
volunteers who
agree to take part in the study
the study was a series of
questions in a semi-structured interview
subdivided into sections
there were different interview schedules
for people with different levels of
computer literacy
a couple of sections were specifically
asking about their experiences of
searching for
health information online and obviously
if they had
they've never used computers before then
those questions were
there was no point in asking them
um and so we ended up with a
distribution as shown
on the slide we actually i actually
managed to get 14 people in rural areas
and 14 in suburban urban areas
but the
the
people were very much skewed to having
some sort of computer literacy
to determine the levels of computers
literacy um i used um the definitions
based on a report by the american
library association
and these are kind of pretty
broad uh categories so
people that were considered to be
non-computer literate you can see here
no knowledge of basic computer functions
didn't know how to open web browsers
or use email
uh the baseline level one was uh how to
open and close web browsers
open a url etc and how to use bookmarks
and the advanced levels
were know the differences between
various internet browsers and their
different versions
and
be aware of the potential security and
privacy threats when using the internet
for the purposes of my study i separated
my sample into level zeros of being
non-computer literate and level one and
two was actually being computer literate
to determine geographical areas
oregon counties have been rated as rural
or suburban urban
based on
a department of agriculture
definitions of
whether they're rural or urban
and which meant that volunteers who
lived in these various counties were
were accordingly
allocated whether they were rural or
suburban
um
the semi-structured interviews used in
the study as i mentioned before split
into a number of sections
um and the sections after each grouping
is shown here on on this slide
the first three
sections demographic information gives
you acuity background and current health
information seeking practices
um were actually the same questions so
they are asked of all of the individuals
the the only separate sections of the
volume ones where the non-computer
literate or the level zero computer
literacy
um
respondents
were asked about their computer and
technology technological usage
whereas the level 1 and level 2 computer
literacy had
questions on internet computer and other
technology use and
their previous experience of health
information retrieval using the internet
so now we go on to the results section
um
due to
current time restraints obviously i
won't resi won't present all of the
results of all of the questions within
my within my study
but a select few
which hopefully can contribute to
answering some of the research questions
um this this slide basically shows the
demographic info of all of the 28
respondents
so
14 and 14 for male and female
the average age whether they are married
or signal at married or single or
divorced
and the highest level of educational
attainment
the
as they're just um figures uh from the
study then we you can see that here
there seems to be a a trend towards
um the people in suburban urban areas
having a higher level of educational
attainment to those with a rural
uh those in rural areas with
nine of the 14 suburban urban response
having completed at least one college
degree
whereas there's only one in the rural
areas
the next section described
the levels of visual acuity that the the
patients
were suffering from
um
the
most common uh problem the most common
form of visual impairment was total
blindness
which is obviously separate from people
who are legally blind
because people were legally blind still
have some sight
but just not
and they're classified
within
uh
the classified as being just legally
blind as opposed to being totally blind
um the second part of this slide
indicates um when they develop their
visual impairment um so quite a number
of the respondents um develop their
visual impairment within their first
year so obviously
um they've never been able to read print
um
whereas some of the the late the the
people who developed their visual
impairment at a later age actually were
able to reprint before
before they developed their visual
impairment which
the final category over 16 and gradually
some of the
some respondents indicated that their
visual impairment was gradually
deteriorated throughout life
there was no one set date where they
could remember that
they started suffering from their
problems
um some of the questions that
that were asked of the entire sample was
how they currently sought health
information um this wasn't specifically
to do with uh whether they searched on
the internet just i was trying to get a
gauge of their um how they search for
health information at the moment and
and who the resources they use to get
that information
um
the most common
most common two categories as you can
see here were
people using either the internet
um or using computers to find
information or just talking to
doctors or other health professionals to
get that information
the second question here is um
who they would actually ask questions
regarding health information maybe
unsurprisingly um the majority
said that they were looking for they
talked to doctors and physicians
and then friends and family and then
other health professionals
um they tended to be um
more
um
specialists in certain areas so if they
had specific um ailments or specific
questions they may ask a specific health
professional who could answer the
question
um
what i did find there seemed to be a
trend
a difference between suburban urban
respondents and rural respondents in the
methods they used with
people in suburban urban areas tending
um being consistently using the internet
and computer
um compared to people in rural areas who
tended more to talk to their doctoral
health professional as their main as
their main method
this slide outlines the type of health
information um that they the respondents
most uh recently thought
and the methods that they employed to
retrieve this information so this is
slightly different from the previous
slide as this is their most recent
search as opposed to just how they
generally searched
um
there was a wide variety of answers
about the type of information they saw
but the most common answer was that they
were searching for specific information
on a disease or an ailment
the methods that they sought
they seemed to
seem to be very similar to the previous
response with
the suburban urban respondents tending
to use the internet or computers to find
their information and the rural people
using the internet computers as well but
also
talking to a doctor or physician
um
all respondents were asked to report on
any barriers or problems they had
encountered when retrieving health
information
um there was a wide variety of answers
here
but the most common response was that
they were frustrated by the use of
printed material
the this seemed to be more common
amongst suburban urban respondents
amongst uh rural respondents it seems to
be having problems with with health
professionals um
and there are a few kind of worrying
comments within this
within this grouping where
one respondent stated that they they
didn't seem to be being taken seriously
all the time
and another responders who actually
stated that
all the health professionals were
condescending to them
the other internet issues
category here
includes
problems of accessing the internet at
home
and knowing
what words to use
in a computer search
respondents were then asked whether they
thought that their visual impairment
actually hindered them when getting
health information
um
found here that half of the respondents
actually said that they they didn't
think it was actually hindering them um
following following that question there
are for the people who
uh stated that they did think it was
hindering in what in what respect
and in what ways did they think their
visual impairment actually hindered them
and communication respect with health
professionals seem to be
common here as well
i guess these are the same people who
commented on the previous question about
the fact that they were having problems
with
health professionals
the uh
the next section
for the computer literate
um
respondents um i was trying to find out
what sort of internet computer and
technology usage they used um how were
they whether they had all the technology
available at home
so rather unsurprisingly the vast
majority did say that they had a
computer at home and also that they they
had internet connection at home
um the next
series of questions i was trying to find
out whether they
needed some specific devices in order
for them to actually use the
computers on the internet
and again the vast majority stated that
they did use
specific devices to enable them to use
the internet and computers
um
the
the final part of this slide indicates
that the the names of the devices that
they most commonly used
um the first two
um options jaws for windows and windows
eyes are both screen reader
software
um
and then the next option is a screen
magnifier and uh zoomtext zoomtext i
think here's the screen
majority kind of i've used screen reader
or screen uh screen magnified in order
to allow them to use the internet
the uh final section actually of the
study actually was the uh looked at the
specific health information retrieval
patterns and experiences of the people
using the internet um this was a section
only answered by the the computer
literate group as well
um
nearly eighty percent of uh the computer
group actually stated that they had used
the uh
the internet to actually search for
health information um at least once
there seemed to be a
trend amongst the suburban urban and the
rural participants where
um
all of the suburban urban respondents
actually stated that they had used the
internet at least once to search for
health information
whereas it was almost 50 50 amongst the
rural patients
following this question there was two
sub-questions asking
for those people who
who didn't use it regularly so those in
the categories of no one once and not
recently
to indicate why they
why they hadn't used the internet to
search for health information when they
used it for other
for other things
and
four of them actually stated that
they've never actually considered it
or they they prefer to use um
talk to doctors
the final question on this slide is it
talks about
uh ask them whether they would
potentially ask somebody else to search
for health information for them on the
internet if they didn't search for them
themselves and if so who they would ask
um this question was asked to see
whether it was just um
their lack of
trust
with the health information on the
internet um as opposed to just
practicalities to see why they hadn't
searched for health information on the
internet uh but all of the respondents
stated that they would potentially ask
somebody else find health information
for them so it obviously wasn't a trust
thing it was just a practicality
um
this slide shows the health information
topics that were most commonly searched
for
and the frequency that the respondents
searching for health information
and how frequently they use they
actually use the internet to search for
health information
once again the
most common answer was that they
searched for information on a disease or
an ailment
but there's also
pharmacy information
drug information etc
the
question regarding how frequently they
searched for health information
seems that the majority
actually search for health information
at least monthly
and in some cases even even more
frequently than that fortnightly
this slide reports on the barriers the
respondents faced and reported when
accessing information for the internet
and the methods that they used in order
to overcome these problems
um
the one of the one of the major problems
was the uh screen readers have problems
sometimes
with photographs and graphics and
certain types of
um
files with one of which are sometimes
recorded on the internet the screen
reader has trouble um
has trouble reading those um which under
the broadboard category of inaccessible
sites um
the screen reader having problems just
accessing all of the information that's
on a specification
website
their
major methods of
overcoming these problems seem to be
kind of almost sidestepping the problems
of going to an accessible site so that
may take three or four sides before they
find
one that's more accessible for their
screen reader or they would call
somebody else to help them
um
this this might be just somebody coming
over and actually reading the
information offer
off the site for them or
um finding some calling somebody and
then actually pointing them in the
direction of a more accessible website
this probably isn't much of a surprise
to anybody living in the 21st century
but it shows
the methods employed
by the people with visual impairment to
retrieve themselves and search for help
information from the internet and the
sorts of websites that they visited
as
the vast majority um used google at some
point to
just so i've been typing search
parameters within google and then go
from sites from there
um
or they
may have used another search engine that
tended to be msn
um
but
less people actually went specifically
to
a major health information website i
guess would be called webmd
you'd probably go to nhs net in the uk
but webmd seems to be the well-known
health website here in the states
um
there are very many
websites noted by
specific individuals which kind of makes
the second part quite difficult to
describe in terms of the data that we
should receive
the specific sites were if they if they
just listed
they may have got a specific ailment and
they went directly to a site that was
related to that site so if they were
suffering from a castle name they may
have gone to a specific site directly
otherwise they may have just used a link
off google
health insurance website once again uh
kind of specific websites like webmd
medline or the mayo clinic there's
actually three
one of the problems of asking these
questions is that if they may have
searched like three or four months ago
and
three respondents actually couldn't
remember the names of the websites that
they actually just from the last
on their last health information search
uh
the respondents were then asked to give
their impression of the sites they
visited
and an impression of how satisfied they
were
with the standard of information that
they received
um
as a whole the
impression that they found was generally
quite positive
um obviously there's a couple of people
there that found that they couldn't
actually find specific themes the
specific information that they were
searching for
with the satisfaction question
um
this was obviously a very subjective um
answer there wasn't a like at scale or
anything we just i just asked them um
what was there how satisfied they were
with the information that they retrieved
um so
majority team again once again seemed to
be reasonably satisfied with the
information they got
i've highlighted that there seems to be
a variation that between pretty and
quite satisfied within suburban areas
and people who are very satisfied in
rural areas but once again this is
purely subjective
this slide shows the length of time on
average the respondents spent when
searching online for health information
and how they would rate their
experiences of searching online
so
the
there's not a whole lot of interesting
information here or relevant information
but you can tell that
they don't spend that much time uh
searching for information maybe
uh under an hour which i would have
it's possible it's pretty similar to how
anybody else would
i guess it really depends on how quickly
they find the information that they're
looking for
the second part here talks about um
how they would
what was their experience when searching
for health information online and
here even though the there were quite a
few positive remarks there was also
quite a few negative ones as well much
more than
when they rated their satisfaction
where a few people suggested that there
was just too much effort as i was
frustrating it was frustrating for them
and that they sometimes had problems
with screen reader which probably goes
back to the
problems with inaccessible sites
their responders will then ask whether
they thought their visual impairment
actually hindered them when searching
for health information online
and if so any what in what ways
um
once again there seems to be a trend uh
between suburban urban response and
rural respondents although the numbers
here are pretty small
um where the suburban urban respondents
seem to
have some uh they they suggested that
their visual impairment
if not always um
hindering them yeah sometimes or yes it
actually did hinder them whereas
there was a slightly bigger percentage
within um
the rural response but once again it's
kind of that the numbers are too small
really to draw too much of a conclusion
from that
um
the ways in which
uh they were being hindered once again
we go back to the inaccessible science
problem
again that seemed to be the major issue
this slide reports on the suggestions
and recommendations recommendations that
respondents would make
enabling to enable them to use the
internet
to search for health information easier
once again we back to the same problems
of screen reader problems not being able
to read photographs making websites more
accessible
there are a wide variety of answers here
once that's why the others categories so
it's so large
all of the computer literate respondents
were then asked whether they thought uh
being able to access health information
online provided greater benefit
uh for people with visual impairment and
if so in in what ways they thought that
that it would um the vast majority
stated that um they thought that it
would
provide greater benefit um and the major
reason seemed to be that they could get
instant access to health information
24 hours a day seven days a week
uh but it would also allow them to um
access
the information in a non-printed form
which is
um was one of their major gripes but it
also one of the interesting things would
be would allow them they thought it
would allow them more freedom
and independence
this slide reports on whether the
respondents fought the health
information
on the internet was trustworthy and
accurate obviously this is a this is
another purely subjective
um but
response to this question um
the majority of the the top or the most
frequent answers here
stated that it will depended on the
specific site and source
of the information the first free answer
all to do with
site related and how trustworthy they
thought the site was rather than the
information um the bottom
the four bottom
variables here
negative responses
were comments
by the individuals that were negative
about the trustworthiness of the system
so
um they may have just said well um
the
they didn't think that the internet was
as trusting as
going to the doctors the question in
responses were comments
where they were questioning where the
info information was coming from uh
before they could determine whether it
was um trustworthy inaccurate
uh comparable responses were comments by
individuals stating they thought the
internet was comparable to other sources
and the rating responses that some
actual people stated well they thought
it was
75 percent accurate or 75 to 80 accurate
uh the final question they're actually
asked was whether
uh
whether they thought that they were
getting comparable health information
uh to those people who did not have
visual impairment
and
here there is a slightly
less positive
than before with but most of most of the
individuals actually thought that they
were getting comparable information um
17 people saying yes five people saying
no
and then two
who were kind of sitting on the fence a
bit
the
the reasons uh for those people who
didn't say that
they were receiving comparable
information what were the causes um and
the main reason was uh physical reason
is that they just couldn't go to a
library and browse books
um there's a
or they it just took longer for them to
get comparable information to
um to normally excited people
right
um so now i'll return back to
my research questions i stated at the
start of the project
and the first research question was
where do people with visual impairment
in oregon go to satisfy their health
information needs and requirements
and kind of maybe
probably unsurprisingly they talked to a
doctor or a health professional or they
used a computer or the internet
but also they sometimes talk to family
friends or someone else who had a
knowledge of the specific ailment or
disease that they were
looking
for
there seemed to be a trend towards
suburban urban respondents using
computer and internet and rural
respondents talking to a doctor or a
health professional
they would primarily ask doctors or
physicians questions regarding health
information
and they make but
conversely they seem to more commonly
trust friends and family to ask
health information
although
doctors and physicians also were rated
pretty highly there as well
uh the second research question what
barriers or obstacles exist that
prohibits or stops those people with
visual impairment
from using online health information
resources um here i've separated them by
their specific groupings so
um
the non-computer literate group uh
stated that it was due to a lack of
knowledge and experience using computers
on the internet
or issues to do with security
or they would prefer to use other
methods
for those computer literate group
respondents who had not used the
internet to search for health
information
they mainly said that they're just not
considered or not just simply not got
around to using the internet for that
purpose
for the computer literate people who had
used the internet there were
problems with inaccessibility of some
websites
and there's also poor methods of
labeling and navigation on those
websites
which led to frustration and problems
people using screen readers
enabling in enabling them to access the
information on these websites
a third research question were were
there variations in the health
information seeking patterns of people
with visual impairment in rural areas
compared to suburban urban areas
once again these trends
that seem to be that their suburban
urban respondents were more likely to
use computer internet to search for this
information
and rural respondents talking to a
doctoral health professional
the most common barrier
seems to be a use and distribution of
printed material for suburban urban
response and problems with condescending
health professionals for rural
respondents
their rural respondents seem to be more
confident that their visual impairment
did not hinder them and will also more
likely seem to be more likely to be
satisfied with the health information
that they received
whereas all suburban urban respondents
stated that they used the internet at
least once to search for health
information these are the computer
literate groupings
whereas only just over half of the rural
responsible state of this
my final research question was what
suggestions or improvements would people
with visual impairment like to see with
relation to health information resources
the respondents stated that um the
accessibility of websites could be
improved um
also they would like the lesson of
sophistication of websites by listening
the amount of non-labeled photograph
pictures and videos the reduction of use
of pdf files which seemed to be a
particular problem with
some of the screen readers
and the creation of health information
websites that were specific to the needs
of the visually impaired
um
as my study is
is pretty small um then some of these
comparisons have to be treated with a
pinch of salt obviously um when you're
comparing a study of 28
um 28 respondents then
i can
create a percentage but obviously when
you're comparing that with a few reports
looking at maybe thousands tens of
thousands of people then
um then there's a potential for um
skewed figures um especially when you
consider that there's a potential bias
of the actual respondents within my
study because as the study was a
volunteers only study then presumably
the people at the oregon commission for
the blind suggested people that would be
more willing
to take part in the study or more likely
to take part in the study and hence
with the people of the oregon commission
for the blind knowing
what my study was looking for they might
push forward people who have a specific
interest in the same areas as my study
so having said that as my major caveats
i'm still going to plunge straight into
comparing my study with previous
research
so the pew report stated that 79 of
internet users searched for health
information
uh whereas the national
telecommunications and information
administration suggested that only 39 of
visually impaired
use the internet for searching payoff
information whereas i found that 79 of
my respondents did
um
so previous the previous another few
reports stated that 38 of disabled
people accessed the internet
whereas 86 of
my response with visual impairment
stated this
so in addition to the caveat about being
a potential bias of my
um
volunteers there's also the fact that
we're not not really comparing like we'd
like here because the 38 of people is
all disabled people as opposed to people
with a disability
as opposed to myself which was just
specifically looking at people with
visual impairment
the most common topic
information about disease
and ailment was the same as found in the
pew report however the next three common
topics in the pew report
to do with
exercise and nutrition
um
weren't actually repeated within within
my study
there was two research studies by barry
and davis that
suggested that people with vision
impairment
but one of the problems with increasing
access to accessible information and
also problems of inaccessible websites
and my study kind of supported these
findings
and it also supported two of the three
hypothesis of beverly
at hal
the only hypothesis they didn't really
support was that
the
people with vision impairment were
disadvantaged
i didn't really find that and the people
i interviewed
didn't give any impression or that they
felt they were disadvantaged so i think
it may be a question of people with
normal side assuming that there are
they know what the problems are of
people with visual impairment
i found that the variation between
geographical areas was
pretty much the same as the pew report
into rural versus suburban areas
so after all of my discussion and
results these are the conclusions that
they
i came up with
the respondents seem to embrace the new
technologies and also the opportunities
for seeking information in an accessible
form that the internet provides
they seem to envision the internet as a
tool that will empower them
and give them more independence and
freedom which is that must be a good
thing
however some response respondents felt
disenfranchised
by their experiences with medical with
the medical profession
and they did not feel that they were
getting comparable health information to
other groupings in society
they tended to be frustrated with the
amount of written and printed health
information that was given to them
but their main barrier and obstacles
seem to be inaccessible websites
one solution possibly would be to
enforce governance on website
accessibility but that's
probably part in the sky it's you'll be
trying to force some sort of legislative
legislation um on the internet which
isn't gonna happen in the in the near
future
this is a slide on uh potential future
research
i've performed kind of
some standard statistical analysis i
didn't find anything statistically
significant amongst the demographic
information and obviously with the
uh with the information i'm retrieving
there can be many different avenues of
searching for additional statistical
analysis on the on the study um
one of the caveats that i should mention
within the results is that most of the
questions uh the number of questions
could have had multiple answers
or open-ended answers so
for the purpose of my study i actually
grouped
specific topics consistent topics
together
the
future research obviously replicating
the study on a wider and
wider scale and also with a larger
sample
to determine whether the consistency of
results that i found
were the same in a bigger population
and also attempting to replicate the
results on a randomly selected group of
people with visual impairment uh once
again this is going back to the
potential bias for people that were
actually volunteered within the um study
because i thought that there was a
potential bias towards um
more technologically aware recipients
just simply
from
the volunteers suggested by the people
of the oregon commission for the plan
so that's pretty much it i have a series
of acknowledgements um richard napolitan
is my future survivor and holly jimison
here at uh here at ohsu and also um
unfortunately winslow parker couldn't
actually make it today but he's
uh he's the adaptive technology
specialist down in the
portland branch of the oregon commission
for the blind and he helped me a lot in
kind of setting up the project and also
locating volunteers within the portland
area and also
in eugene uh the other acknowledgement
uh jan hearing um who works down in the
oregon commission for the blind in coos
bay
um
she was uh somebody who
was very important within the study to
get will be all uh get all the rural
recipients um i found it very difficult
at the start of the study to find any
people that i could find within rural
areas to actually take part in the study
but fortunately i got in contact with
jan hearing and she managed to round up
an equivalent number of rural pa uh
rural volunteers for me and obviously
the volunteers and the participants who
actually declined to study um i'm sure
it wasn't particularly
fun for them to have some english guy
coming turning up
coming to their house and then asking
them questions for 45 minutes sticking a
tape recorder in their face
um so obviously i'm very grateful for
those people and hopefully
the information that they volunteered
and can be useful in some way
to helping them
yeah in the in the future
uh so these are my about two pages of
references
and
that's it for my presentation so thank
you
and if you have any further questions
any questions
can you press your student mic
apparently um so on one of your slides
you talked about tailoring sites to the
needs of people who are visually
impaired
and does that mean you know taking the
existing content and making it more
accessible or creating you know
different kinds of content and if so
what would that content look like uh
well pretty much the two things that you
just suggested that probably
work hand in hand together um if you if
you make the content of a website more
accessible then
then
and also in a format that makes it
accessible for the screen readers then
you've got around the problem of of
making the site almost tailored towards
that sort of visual impairment
obviously the legislation at the moment
doesn't cater specifically for people
with visual impairment anyway it's kind
of for any people with disabilities so
um
yeah so i mean some of the accessibility
problems are due to screen reader
problems so that
obviously they're going to be
software that may be used more
frequently by people with visual
impairment as opposed to other groupings
so the other part of the question was
that um you know you sort of presented
the fourth hypothesis early that maybe
uh visually impaired people need a
different content it sounds like are you
what you found is that they actually
could use the same content but it just
had to be more yeah excessive yeah i
judging from the um the topics they were
searching for they i mean the major
topics seem to be the same sort of
information
and i mean if you think of it
intuitively you probably
that's the conclusion that you would
reach is that they would actually to
the types of health information that
they were looking for beyond maybe
research into specific eye problems that
they may encounter or
looking for health insurance or
something that may
uniquely affect them
then the rest of the potential health
issues that they may search for are
going to be similar you would afford
with the general population
i i don't i don't know your names
did you you measured when they were oh
you collected information about when
they were uh visually impaired did that
have any bearing on any of the answers
um to be honest i haven't actually
looked into that area at all
as of yet but i mean that could be
something that i could do
within the final
report
your data showed a differential of the
rural respondents to your urban suburban
respondents
despite the fact that
they had as you showed equal access
to the internet and
computers
i'm curious if you saw any anecdotal
information with regard to the
relationship to their health
professionals given that that was their
alternate source to get information well
i mean
they
they seem to use um doctors and health
professionals more in order to get their
health information but they also
reported problems
that they'd encountered when trying to
retrieve that information that seemed to
be
a consistency or maybe not consistency
but a reporting of
um
health professionals being condescending
or kind of not treating them seriously
for problems so even even with those
uh barriers that they've encountered
they still seem to be using that method
to retrieve their health information
rather than
using the internet so you would have
thought there may have been a
if there if they are encountering those
problems that they may try a different
methodology to retrieve that health
information but i didn't actually see
that within the
within my research
um i have a suggestion on the question
suggestion first
you could use uh
charts and graphs instead of tables
because it's hard for me to read
patterns from your numbers from your
tables okay
the graphs i think would be more
visually appealing
that's true
and the question i'm not sure if i have
followed the methodology that you have
used to arrive at your conclusions could
you could you elaborate on that
uh
what you mean by
how did you did you do some statistical
analysis oh okay um
the the actual questionnaire
uh was a series of as i mentioned
initially as a
series of different sections in each
section there were specific questions
some of them required a yes no answer
and some of them were
um just
so i mean
just general questions that the
respondent could answer in any way that
they
wanted to and so sometimes you've got
multiple answers if
for example
if they used one of the questions would
do you think that being able to access
health information online prevent
provides potentially greater benefit for
people with visual impairment so that
would be a yes or no answer to start
with but then they could elaborate and
then give multiple answers why they
thought that
it would provide potentially greater
benefits so what i did then was take the
the responses that they gave and then
allocated kind of groupings so if there
was consistent findings they may have
commented in a slightly different manner
but you could say well i use a computer
or something like that and i i use
search on google and then some other
individual might say well i use the
internet so you can group those together
people who use the internet
or whatever to
answer that um
so obviously with a statistical analysis
it's going to be
slightly problematic to
because of the fact i'm
actually physically grouping them myself
rather than otherwise we'll have
multiple different comments from
multiple different individuals but with
some of the basic demographic
information then you can do the
statistical analysis on that
because of the fact you've got finite
answers as it were so i don't know if
that happened that explains it or not
yes
um unless your total sample is 28 and
the results it drops down to 24
sometimes i see that's excluding the
four people yeah there was four people
that were considered to be non-computer
literate so then a bunch of them are 18
who who is that excluding okay so uh
sorry i should have explained this um
we started off with with 28 patients
four
were considered to be non-computer
literate so they answered um
different sections hence why the n
equals 24
at the start of the final section which
asks them whether they'd search for
health information online
there are a number of questions
um that were only asked of people who
would search for health information
online obviously
the people that were excluded with the
people that suggested that who said that
they hadn't set health information
online so obviously the questions
relating to their experiences in that
area and they were excluded from but
they they answered the subset of
questions which asked them
um if they why they didn't use basically
why they didn't use helping why they can
use the internet search health
information whereas they use the
internet regularly forever so
they were they were in a sub sub group
so
that's why the ends fluctuate
well thank you for the time
and
this one section
um